seeing my father's infidelity being
abused by this old retired mailman and
yes didn't really know what a healthy
relationship is or was there wasn't a
stable Father Figure in my life Cheryl
Burke opens up about her personal
history with abuse and I feel like that
a lot of people that have experienced
something similar to this probably feel
the same way while chatting with the
ladies of red table talk Jada and Gammy
and psychologist Dr Alfie the Dancing
with the Stars pro reveals her earliest
memory of trauma happened during
childhood after her stepdad allegedly
hired a family friend a retired mailman
to babysit her he was in his 60s it was
more of a grooming experience because it
wasn't intercourse it was others you
know stuff that happened sexual acts but
I never physically felt hurt like there
was moments and I'm gonna say it now
like it didn't feel bad it was actually
intimate right yeah he was grooming me
yeah and he was my definition of love I
actually testified against him at nine I
believe oh for me you know I've let that
go and I'm not gonna let him ruin who I
am today shortly after that experience
Cheryl found her passion competitive
dancing I mean thank God for dancing it
saved my life but she claims the abuse
continued in other relationships
including with her High School boyfriend
I'll never forget the person I was with
on and off for about four years whipped
me with a belt
oh okay and I had bruises all over my
legs I remember his parents were
watching it didn't do anything but I
would see these welds and even that I
was like oh if that's not really there
wow I think I was in shock and fight
flight or freeze it was just that
feeling of no self-worth no self-esteem
that same feeling of please don't leave
me no matter what you do to me I had no
self-respect for myself as for why
Cheryl feels like she kept falling for
allegedly abusive men I just was not
attracted to the nice guy I'll never
forget my very first competitive dance
partner so sweet I was so disgusted by
how sweet he was and I was only
attracted to chauvinistic
men yeah what you're gravitating to is
what feels familiar right it feels like
home eventually Cheryl met her now
ex-husband Matthew Lawrence we dated
like when I first got into this business
in 2006 and then took a break for a
decade dated again an X for a reason
right fast forward to 2018 they
reconnected and their romance was back
on what was it that made you guys know
you know we want to do this again and
even we want to hit the red carpet or
the orange carpet together for me it was
like a text message last December saying
hey wanna have dinner Merry Christmas
and then that was it and despite Cheryl
admitting a lot of my friends thought I
was ever going to get married the two
tied the knot in 2019 and Cheryl
explains why I think for me and I'm not
it has nothing to do with my ex
whatsoever I wanted to see if I could
get married because there was a lot of
this internal like am I good enough and
I think a lot of us women yeah feel that
way it's like you know what if
somebody's willing to marry me yes then
I must be worth after less than three
years of marriage Cheryl filed for
divorce from Matthew see I don't wish I
I did anything differently I think you
know we did try and when it comes to
ever marrying again she's not completely
opposed to it there's moments for sure
of sadness and um reflection and just
wanting to be able to share your life
with somebody and I'm not definitely not
saying I'll never get married again for
sure
foreign